yes
changes
that's a that's an angry fish yeah the
fish the angry fishes
oh i see it's very similar
next thing i'm going to break out my
nutty professor hey ladies
dave landau we have so much to talk
about today listen
first off let me tell you this i wish
i wish that i didn't have to talk about
gun control but when it's the
first trending hashtag after a shooting
about which we know
nothing you would think that the media
had learned their lesson from accusing
uh
or at least i should say uh covering
lying about the previous uh shooting as
a hate crime when we found out that uh
you know 33
of the people shot were white and then
it was a guy who thought he had sex
addiction
you'd think they learned their lesson to
not jump the gun forgive the pun but
don't
but now they're doing the exact same
thing we know almost nothing at the time
of this recording very little aside from
10 dead which is horrible it's a tragedy
and i want to before we talk about this
we're also talking we'll also be talking
about maternity suits
oh yeah in the military for pilots yeah
here's the phrase
to be more tolerant we need to build
maternity suits for female
fighter pilots that won't turn your kid
into a goofball
yeah no not at all by the time you're by
the time you're done reenacting torah
torah torah in your
inside your it's just gak
people who you remember nickelodeon
nickelodeon remember that then you stick
your thumb and go
it could be flubber it could be flubber
it won't move as much
right well then it could be you know
robin williams post flubber
oh this grey was cold i turned it into
it okay
anyway this is a rough start no that's
not you dave this is on me
uh we have to talk about uh gun control
and we have to talk about the lies right
now that are circulating i wish that we
were in a world where
every single tragedy was not immediately
politicized but you cannot allow false
information to go
on unchecked so we are going to do that
and uh of course i want to hear from you
guys in the comments section pretty soon
we'll be reading your hate mail as well
we'll have mark roberto in to do it oh
nice
gerald a how are you today how are you i
am terrible how are you
quarter black i'm doing great yeah look
he's come to grips with the fact that
he's accepted amongst no communities
he's a man with no home
dave linda how are you ahoy i am good uh
i'm excited to talk about gun control
with you wearing a gun holster this is a
good look for me this is a very good
look for uh
i'm kidding it's a good look for all of
us once you sit in the chair in this
show
you have to stop worrying about optics i
do yeah i do
okay um first off though before all this
let's talk about kamala harris yesterday
was asked if she would visit the border
and a lot of people and we have the
first clip and then we have obviously
the the edit
right um no we don't we don't okay well
kamala harris was asked if she was going
to visit the border and uh
she laughed and said not today so we
actually we
and i warn you a little disturbing we
have the clip do you plan to visit the
border
not today
that's news news oh it's like dr hibbard
without the charm
yes well you mean like new dr hibbert
from a white guy oh yeah that's right
yeah
right yeah oh no sorry wait no from a
non-white guy he's going to be a black
guy the other yeah
the point is doesn't go the other way
you can't why change perfection why
mess with perfection black voice is a
thing now
really it's about representation that's
separation
it's my issue with family guy uh with uh
cleveland
yeah they decided to make him a black
guy where you go
you have so many racist jokes in every
episode
was he not a black problem he was not a
black guy oh
really i don't want a voice i don't want
to live in america anymore
where a man cannot get a 40 million
dollar contract because of his race
precluded
as cleveland because of his race well if
we're not gonna let
people play characters it's not really
acting is it if the paraplegic guy is
just paraplegic you can't really win a
trophy for acting paraplegic
you would think not but they do well
they've done that with transgenders
they're like that's beautiful and brave
well he just acted like himself
he was just she was distraught and uh
and uh unhappy and surly and spread
surreptitious rumors without any
substantiation that's not academy award
were they
by the way hey listen you guys can uh
listen to the podcast your audio only
like last week some of the stuff got
removed but it's still available on
apple
android spotify and the best thing to do
is just check into the show it's a live
show
monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern and look comment comment that's
the best thing you can do comment below
what what do you think is going to
happen here with gun control and do you
find it a little weird that you know
listen i don't
there weren't that many mass shootings
under donald trump that's something i'm
saying nothing heard about it
notwithstanding yeah of course that's
not including all the writing
well and we'll get to that in a second
the false statistics where you maybe
believe that most mass shooters are
white
no so we'll talk about it but first uh
ron desantis
uh this is just i i think this is the
guy who needs
to probably grow up for president he's
going to especially after what happened
with christy noem and i understand the
legal issues there she's not she's not
pro
transgender men in sports that's not
yeah
conservatives need to stop abandoning
someone because they don't wait for the
details however
desantis i don't need to wait for
details it's black or white simplistic
reductive
i love the man call me here he is
addressing a reporter
when asking about the public's scandal
for
have donated vaccines 000 to your
campaign
so first of all that what you're saying
is wrong that's that that's a fake
narrative
so first of all when we did the the
first pharmacies that had it were cvs
and walgreens
and they had a long-term care mission
we've done almost 75 percent of the
seniors
in palm beach and the reason is because
you have the strong retail footprint
and it's wrong it's wrong it's a fake
narrative i just disabused you of the
narrative
and you don't care about the facts
because obviously i laid it out for you
in a way
that is irrefutable and so it's clearly
not
no no no you're wrong you're wrong
you're wrong yes sir
[Music]
i didn't know much gang violence in
florida yeah man
it must be rampant it's new strange and
you should listen to his whole answer
because he sets the context very well no
no we rolled this out with
cvs with walgreens for a couple of weeks
as part of their mission then we wanted
more retail positions
this is what the left tries to do they
go oh wait hold on a second there's
money from some conservatives that must
mean they're funding everything yeah
right and i know what you're saying
you're going to say well concerns do it
with george soros
that would apply if he didn't fund
everything he literally didn't do it
this is what we were talking about
desantis this is how he is better in
this
one thing than donald trump was he is
great at putting it right back in your
face but also giving you
really good detailed facts he's really
good at tasting donald trump a lot of
times would just be like wrong you raw
and move on to something right i
wouldn't actually tell you
why you're wrong desantis goes the extra
mile and it's like here's why you're
wrong and here's why this is going to be
run on
every competing news agency i was
talking with quarterback garrett about
this is what donald trump is
donald trump seems like the guy at first
glance right who if he were doing a
sketch on sesame street like a celebrity
with a puppet
he'd like get mad at the puppet but then
you realize he'd get mad at the
puppeteer like stop
all the actors excuse me excuse me
excuse me listen you're not fooling
anyone with your sticker
with your hand up it says stop that's
what he does and he shows you
look there's a puppeteer that's what
he's showing you know you're lying this
is dishonest you cannot allow the left
to set
the narrative and then try and argue
down that path that's something that
we've done with changed my mind that's
something we'll do in the future we'll
be doing more change my minds
um it really is terms matter
you need to have terms and conditions
before you start
and that is why today no we're going to
cut it off at the past as it relates to
gun control i want to know what you
think is the most egregious
gun control measure we've covered it a
few times in the past but a lot of
people
need a bit of a refresher let's uh look
really quickly before we move on to the
colorado shooting let's look at cnn
and see how they're covering it this
issue even though chuck schumer the
majority leader of the senate
just said on the senate floor that he
would try and that this senate
would address the issue of gun violence
but how exactly that is dress
addressed remains to be seen one senator
a wyoming freshman cynthia alumnus i
just asked her
whether or not her opposition to
expanding background checks has
exchanged
in any way she said that her view is
that expanding background checks
would be quote an erosion that would
chip away
on second amendment that's correct
shared by
many republicans in the senate so even
though the democrats plan to push ahead
even though they're pointing to this
massacre
after another and saying that something
needs to be done
okay let's just i can't i can't i can't
i can't
i don't want i don't wanna i don't want
to be another statistic where i stick a
gun in my mouth
okay that's why if i watch cnn too much
if i take myself out it'll be a bottle
of pills i'll hang myself razor blades
just so that i don't give anderson
cooper the satisfaction take away from
her
i just don't want to make a mess well
listen at that point i don't know pills
but you're probably gonna vomit
well i've thought about it though you
ruined that hotel then your family's got
to pay for it
yeah you go just straight pills are a
mess though just
take the pills and throw yourself off a
rail in the ozarks that's better that's
probably the way to do it
so first thing who here owns a firearm
okay everyone here owns a firearm let me
ask everyone
you watching do you own a firearm okay
for those who are blaze
blaze members when you bought a firearm
what'd they do they basically said here
take it run away no i had a background
check they tried to confirm who i was
show the id make sure everything's
correct
what about you uh i bought it off a
paper bag off a guy named e-ray oh
which really the paper bag was just for
display purposes right
he seemed very legit yes but he was very
used compassionate
he was he's like the dr kavorkian of
selling saturday night specials but when
you purchased it
honestly yeah they uh actually they had
to take my information
and they called me a couple days later
to pick it up well this is in new york
detroit really michigan yeah there's a
waiting period waiting period there is a
waiting period well that's ridiculous so
when they say background checks they say
most republicans support background
checks
sure they already exist they already
exist there isn't a loophole there are
already background checks and that's why
we started that gift a gun hashtag a
while ago because
all that is needed for someone to
understand that cnn is
full of [ __ ] that they are lying to
you is to have ever
purchased one firearm legally whatever
now you can say there's an online
loophole meaning that some people buy
firearms illegally that's not a loophole
breaking the law
illegal so what we're talking and we'll
get to what the hr 127 is proposing
exactly so you understand what they mean
by this and truth be told they don't
know what they mean
they say military style weapons and they
don't even know what it means so we
need to know what it means but every
single person here has purchased
firearms i have many firearms always
within reach
and uh every single one background check
yeah yep
there is no way to get one with so
here's what we know about the colorado
show well there are ways to get it
yes legally well yes oh no illegally
but i'm just saying there you can
illegally obtain them of course
but legal criminals are gonna criminal
but i don't know how the an expanded
background check is gonna stop that
right
well if it starts where they go hey we
should check some people out like damn i
was going to get a gun
all right can i hold on let me get my
ipad all squares
get my information [ __ ] welcome to the
[ __ ] registry
yeah just want to sit down we will break
a lot of laws like the dmv
hey i told you i'm sorry white ass
before pull a ticket
so what happened here's exactly what we
know 10 people were killed including one
police officer
uh 51 year old eric talley horrible
tragic
i want to be clear unless we can rule
some people here the police escorted the
suspect from the scene
at the time of this show we don't know
his name but of course he's white and so
the media is talking about mass shooters
being white because they see everything
through
the prism of race the shooting occurred
at king super supermarket
at roughly 2 30. i didn't even know king
super's two o's was a thing
yeah i think the super supermarket
didn't help yeah
i would just avoid shopping at uh names
that are shops that have names that are
spelled wrong
oh as a general rule or use super twice
regardless of spelling that's true or if
it's like cool with a k
yeah i don't like well that's probably
getting shot unless it's cigarettes
because then it's pretty cool
that's right am i right guys talk about
branding yes
we know that this arsenio hall audience
won't be purchasing chesterfields
cool with a k that's my [ __ ] i think
newports for many many years really yes
newports i don't even know if they still
make them
no they do well chesterfield's where
doctor recommended number one so that's
what i want to talk to they have a nice
smooth pull
oh very nice one out of nine no no thank
you eight out of nine doctors i thank
them from the bottom of my closet
so this is something now now let's go
through the claims that are being made
this is really important that we get
through these here
um one of the claims that is is uh i
guess you would say
uh most consistent this happens with all
shootings but right now they're saying
uh well this happened in colorado
specifically because they didn't enforce
what you've heard of and again
the terms matter because people go
assault weapons yeah that sounds scary
yeah
i saw i saw cobra i know that's bad
right people shouldn't have that must be
a
bazooka
is bad cobra is bad but it's wonderful
but it's a great musical weapon he used
in 1911. so they say
this shooting occurred because the
assault weapons ban
wasn't enforced don't take my word for
it can you tell me about why you're here
and
while you're outside i got the call from
my daughter that my grandchildren and my
son-in-law
work walked into the pharmacy for him to
get a
coven 19 shot and the shooter came in
shot the woman in front of them they had
ran upstairs or hiding in a coat closet
for the last
hour and this is a put in a big pitch
for
gun control well you did get a shot
well didn't you expect him to answer did
you expect him to answer
well listen i'm just asking questions i
want to know the facts
about what's going on with the shooting
i think that this is the result of
fluoride in your tap
he does is definitely a ventura
so here's the deal uh there is nothing
to tell us
that an ar when people say assault
weapons ban they think ar-15
ar15 does not stand for assault rifle by
the way it stands for arma light
uh would have had any impact on this so
let's be really clear about let's let's
go through some statistics a lot of
people think
ar-15s that's a scary black rifle that's
the rifle that was used here
assault weapons ban is going to make a
dent in mass shootings according to new
york times
weapons used in mass shootings 11 out of
19 didn't use any kind of a rifle at all
let alone an ar-15 a rifle of any sort
we've talked about handguns
are used uh 19 times
as many as far as kills in this country
as far as murders yeah all rifles put
together
so 19 times more likely to be shot by a
handgun
than by a rifle 11 out of 19 mass
shootings didn't involve a rifle at all
uh i can remind you virginia tech that
was all with
handguns yeah that's great um and then
by the way according to fbi statistics
you're
four times more likely to die uh from
being knifed to death
uh than by being shot by rifle a little
bit higher if you're in your city khan's
uh municipality um
or in the uk yeah same thing that's what
you know he's the mayor of london yeah
or
ah piss off my friend johnny knife
johnny you know that's it's almost not
fair
no but if you upset him you're gonna die
by knife
that's my thing that's what i do
sometimes like you know
he's having his midlife crisis with a
therapist i was thinking
maybe i could be like johnny knife and
you know sock full of quarters or maybe
johnny knife and revolver like no no
no no no we've made some progress some
real headway here it's johnny knife and
nothing else for you okay doc
niche kids right joey's sock and a lock
joey's sucking a look it's locking a
sock blocking us
i have dyslexia today you punk i'm john
knife
guess what's gonna happen next you're
getting knifes you're gonna meet jesus
from my knife oh joey swords
buys a lot of stuff off infomercials
joey katana
and over here this is a tommy reverse
mortgage we just keep him around for
sound financial advice okay you just
wish you were dead
yeah this is johnny he'll flatten one of
your tires so you can't go nowhere
right and then this guy's gonna wear you
down about doing a reverse
mortgage by the end of it it's gonna
make sense
hey you're done uh this is something
else that they're claiming
uh that this of course right now they're
running with this narrative because we
saw the guy who looks like a fine
upstanding citizen
but you notice there's a lack of melanin
or as nick cannon and cardi b say lack
of soul
uh they say they said like melanin in
his soul
yeah yeah i don't know they believe that
black people have souls and white people
don't some of these black supremacists
can and included am i the only one who
agrees well as far as i don't know how
much seoul as far as
uh oh well yeah it's not all otis and
the knights or whatever that band was
uh good lattice night in the pips animal
house oh you're talking about animal
house
mind if we dance with your dates otis my
man
my man brought it for you so this is
another myth that they are now parroting
is uh
this is another example of white men
disproportionately committing
mass shootings don't take my word for it
biggest terror threat
in this country is white men
most of them radicalized right up to the
right most of these shooters
are young white men and these four young
men have something in common
they wanted to kill lots of people they
wanted to commit
mass murders and they were angry
young white males well first of all i
just think it's very interesting
that we're talking about racially
profiling in the context of mass
shootings um
the the vast majority of people who are
doing the mass shootings in america
are not muslims at all so exactly the
young white men
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] so
let me walk you through why and by
can we just be clear about something too
when people say hey why is he being
escorted and the other guy was shot
that's because he's white no
look look the purpose for a police
officer officer to shoot somebody
is to remove the threat okay so there's
a huge difference in most of these cases
including
black and white when they aren't shut on
the spot is because they are not waving
their gun around they've surrendered
their firearm do you understand that
regardless of race there's a huge
difference between
a gang shooting melee or remains saying
you'll never take me alive
and a guy behind a door with the cop
saying come up with your hands up all
right
here i'm sliding out the weapon i'm
coming out with my hands up
there's a huge difference to try and say
it's exclusively due to
race is dishonest and again it breeds
more racism
those chickens have come home to roost
right now with over 80 percent of
all violent attacks on asians being
carried out by black americans
because you've divided and conquered
with affirmative action with the idea of
gun crime with the idea of poverty rates
with the idea of people who are taking
their jobs
this is what the left has done you will
breed more racism here
if you convince young black males that
they'll be shot on sight
and white people won't solely because of
race that's not
accurate what else is completely
inaccurate is the idea that most of
these shootings take place from uh
overwhelmingly white males that's not
true
that's not true well and this is this is
what the left does with statistics they
basically give you kind of a sliver of
something true
but it doesn't tell the story it doesn't
help explain what's going on and it's
not useful in solving the problem
and it's a lie you're being generous
with the slivers they give you a crumb
too small for a mouse
that's true okay well that's true
okay honest question yeah so let's say
you have
there are a lot of angry white guys who
shoot places up let's just sub
and i would assume that there will be
more of it when you decide to destroy
the economy and lock them in their house
for months on end yeah
to remove their jobs and their business
um but there there
certainly is uh an epidemic of that with
a lot of people
whatever yeah why are they saying it's a
mass shooting is it just
are you saying that the in black
communities yeah
you're saying those are mass shootings
is that the argument so here's here's
what
there's what the statistics matter
because they will use one set of
statistics when making one argument from
the left and they'll use another
statistic in another argument so let me
give you an example right now they will
say
look the vast majority of mass shootings
are from white males right but here's
the thing
what they do and i actually have this
right now from mother jones this is the
one that's been circulated
uh that includes that 60 of shooters are
white males by the way in 2015 it was 70
something percent so the black lives
matter riots have changed that
statistically single-handedly
that includes all middle eastern people
north africans as white and it
completely excludes gang crimes now why
does that matter because mass
shootings are defined as four people
killed or more now when these same
people say we have more mass shootings
than any other country which is a lie
they include the totality which is gang
crimes which make up
the huge majority of mass shootings so
they want one set of statistics
mostly white people but you excluded
gang crime and you included middle
eastern people as well as people from
egypt uh like was it egypt libya uh
algeria
morocco i've seen true romance
well and dave it's not precise right so
it's like it's kind of like saying that
i'm in the top one percent of athletes
in the united states it's probably not
too too far off congratulations here's
the thing you're trying to evaluate me
to see if i can play in the nfl that
doesn't really tell you anything i need
you need to go drill down how about in
college okay now how about compared to
people in the nfl the stat matters only
if it's relevant and useful and it's not
useful to say
well white men are committing more of
these crimes than anybody else well okay
well what percentage of the population
are they
what other factors are there so we can
kind of drill down on that that's a
horrible analogy you boastful mick
it is what uh notre dame we get it
so uh mother jones right they follow the
fbi definition for mass shootings
excludes gang uh violence uh or drug
violence right or why
and then here's the thing since 1982
there have been exactly 122 mass
shootings
right that again excludes gang violence
it's the point though that the gang
violence is more we
we get the idea of it we know it it's
involved and they're saying that the
white shooter is sort of
you don't know the motivation they can
say that but you don't necessarily know
um right because gang violence
unfortunately there's a lot of
collateral damage and that's why they
decided to include those in mass
shootings the idea that gang violence
only affects
those in the gangs is untrue absolutely
despite what killer mike tries to say
you even know i'm a fan of run the
jewels
gang violence makes up 75 to 85 percent
of homicides in inner cities like
chicago
okay nationally 35 percent of gang
members are black 46
latino just to be clear since the
beginning of 2021 they've already been
527
shootings in chicago 527 shootings in
chicago that means that about 420
of those shootings were due to gangs
four times as many mass shootings
here it's getting nicer yeah it's
getting and by the way that's important
this is the issue is let's lock
everybody down let's shut down their
businesses let's remove their ability to
feed their families let's create a
mental health epidemic like we've never
seen in this country
and then what we do is remove guns from
people who need to protect themselves
from all the other crazy people who've
gone stir crazy who have cabin fever
this is a
powder keg and you guys just want to
remove firearms from people who can't
afford security details yeah and it's
worse than that you're vilifying or
you know making the villain out of every
single white person in the country right
now either because you're a second
amendment
advocate right you own a firearm and you
think people should be able to own
firearms
or you're a racist just because you're
white right you have inherent racism in
you
and so you're making these people out to
be the bad guys and and
i think dave the point that we're making
here is that yes there are white people
that end up doing very bad things and we
have to get a handle on why people do
what they do
so that we can stop it in the future
right but if you only focus on this one
part of the problem that isn't making up
the vast majority of the problem
statistically
you're missing out on the chicago well
what if you're out on gang violence
here's the thing let's
remove race from it right now again i
hate that we have to do this that's
because that's immediately the narrative
that the media runs
do you know what is the single most
consistent what congress statistic with
these mass shooters
uh like what do you think they all have
in common bullets
that as well some look i'm just here
i i i'm trying to ask god no no no no no
no no no no no no i know i also make
jokes but
do you know what it is most of them
don't have a dad oh before before 2020 i
think it was something like 38 of the 39
we had those statistics
it's the vast it's 90 something percent
of them don't have a father come from a
broken household
go watch my wife and i were watching um
what is it i am a murderer
or uh confessions of a murderer where
it's each episode is a murderer
confessing
every single one would come the first
person like well you know i was
jumping around foster families and then
i finally found my dad adopted me but he
raped me till i was 12 and so you know
after that i had like four relatively
good and they're talking about this and
there's another guy saying you know my
dad walked out on me
and uh i had to sell drugs to make a
living and then for some reason the left
thinks that adding i don't know two
three let's add four thousand dollars
per pupil spending in public schools
will fix that problem
well simultaneously actively destroying
the fiber of this country the nuclear
family a mother
a father and children and incentivizing
a mother and a father to stay together
they've
they've actually incentivized people to
not get married and get divorced and it
is overwhelming if you're going to look
for a correlation
it's not race doesn't come out as
strongly right socioeconomic status
doesn't correlate as strongly
not having a father is the single
greatest statistic that we have it's
also the single greatest indicator
as to whether you finish school whether
you have behavioral problems whether you
go to college
whether you run a business whether you
get married whether you're an abusive
relationship yourself
this is but we entirely ignore it let's
go really quickly to this on this this
uh this guy talking who uh mr potato
officer
eric talley was was doing as he lost his
life in the line of duty
he was heroically trying to save others
the state of colorado has 35
people from the colorado bureau of
investigations and state troopers
assisting the investigation since
yesterday we've offered to help with
victim services
as well all right well guys hey let's
have the control room keep an eye on it
let me know if anything
new happens because again we're
broadcasting this live as information is
coming out so i do want to provide you
with what we do have
but doesn't this cut become about race
where
when you will you look at it immediately
if if there is a
shooter of color all of a sudden it does
break down to okay this is the reason
why
these are the reasons why this is why
it's almost uh acceptable or forgiven or
whatever it might be and then if the
other the shooter is white which i don't
know that guy could be arab
and his leg was red i don't know if he
was shot
could have been a little bit nathan
phillips yeah but it but all of a sudden
it just breaks down to well it's
obviously homegrown terrorism and some
level of
of racism racism that's the problem is
that we look through everything with
this prism of race
yeah no no we only do it one mass
shooting did he specifically only shoot
black people do we know that
no no okay they don't know police
officers and they also didn't
specifically only shoot
asian people no no yeah yeah so i just
want to be clear when people say yeah
race here's the thing i think and i
think you're right look
i think with gang violence often the
motive is pretty clear now when we say
terrorism for example if it's a brown
person it's because they have a mission
statement that says i'm doing this to
bring glory to allah that is terrorism
it's usually a manifesto right
when you read a written statement from a
white guy who says peanut butter on
bread and my phone is talking to me like
well maybe this guy isn't an
international terrorist maybe he's just
a dummy it does
motive in that case is what determines
whether it's homegrown terrorism
or not and right now of course they want
to set the narrative that homegrown
white terrorism is a greater threat than
people who are burning down cities right
now
in the name of what is effectively a
terrorist organization if you look at
the black lives matter charter
it is to destroy all systems in place
that exists right now in american
institutions
that's that's in their charter it is the
destruction of the nuclear family
that's in the charter of black lives
matter if you had that from a white
person right they'd read that be like oh
my gosh look at this guy
look can we believe look at this
homegrown tears the destruction of the
nuclear family well this guy must hate
anyone who's not white
but for some reason we give it a pass
with black class matter we give it a
pass with antifa
we don't know what's going on with this
guy if this guy said hey
i want to go out and kill as many black
people as possible because i'm a racist
and he just you know held the map upside
down so it didn't result in any kind of
success for him because he didn't shoot
only black people
i'll be the first person to say hey this
guy's a racist terrorist but we don't
know that yet and statistically we know
that it's not the same kind of problem
and it certainly is not the kind of
problem that affects
black americans throughout this country
in inner city
inner cities black children right now
are far
more likely and black adults to be shot
by other
black americans not mass shooters who
are white
yeah well i think we also have to look
at the shutdown too where
right there's two different levels of
that where in a lot of black communities
everything's been taken from you now
you're turning to drugs not that they
weren't there before but i think you're
going to get more than before
right now you also have this white area
where a lot of people think they have to
strive to be so successful everything's
taken away from them
they feel useless which then can either
make you suicidal or a killer
so i think a lot of this stuff does
breed from over the last year not that
shootings are a new thing
no but i do think that a lot of what's
happened in the last year has caused
people to lose their mind
and go in a direction that is sometimes
more commonplace per
yeah group well that's the thing the
left only cares about mental health when
they can use it for
a background check because if you've
ever taken a xanax you can't purchase a
firearm you now lost your right to
self-preservation
that's what the left does right now we
know statistically we have the biggest
mental health epidemic that has ever
happened
in this country because we've locked
people down and removed their
and by the way for a lot of you that's
your own fault if you've stayed home and
not
actually hugged your family members
shame on you yeah shame on you
shame on you if you've quarantined your
children and sequestered them away from
you
that's you living in fear and deciding
that you're going to let your children
pay the bill okay
this all has to stop now we
know where it leads you're a mother
you're a father
you're a son you're a daughter you're a
member of the community stop
locking yourself in your house and only
going out double masking so that you can
go to
super super whatever it is uh in which
case we know that this doesn't end well
what were you doing i was gonna say dave
just did more analysis than cnn ever
does with a shooting like this because
dave is trying to get to the root of the
problems right
dave can help solve the problem cnn is
trying to make sure that people push a
narrative so that guns get taken away
from the scary white man
yes well listen you're tall and you
played at notre dame so people are right
to be fearful
and i'm short well you know shorter ones
are crazier
i i i posed for notre dame there's like
a little bull terrier
that's what happens the shorter ones
have to do crazier stuff to like that's
always it's like ironic name like oh
yeah that's
big that's big davey yeah but he's small
but he does big things
that's what they always say about me
more so than johnny knife johnny knife
is terrified of
big davy johnny knife will cut anybody
but big dave he's huge cause he knows
that big baby's gonna come back
hard let's see what this guy is saying
right now the guy who tries to fake talk
like obama on uh this guy who sits there
and he talks like this watch watch
he's faking it pick up groceries to buy
eggs
some of them to get a copy vaccine in a
mere
instant community was upturned
by a senseless act of violence
this year's coloradans we've faced a lot
of challenges
self-imposed and in this year you
imposed
due to covet of loss and of loneliness
i certainly went through the carlton at
a party once yes they've been wonderful
and they always complain
you keep on treating me like i'm a
little kid routine
activities that we've continued to
engage in as coloradans and
as americans it's hard to describe
what it means for this safe place
to see a horrible tragedy like this
unfold now once upon a time in the
united states of america
he would just talk about the tragedy and
what we can do to help those members
let's see how long can we put on a timer
to see how long it takes before he gets
to the gun control narrative
i didn't plan on doing this today with
this show and i'm sure the previous guy
did
i'm willing to bet it's coming here in
the next two minutes and how long has he
been speaking so
everyone you can watch along with me
place your bets all right let's see
in our movie theaters and in our
communities
we need to see your change because we
have lost far too many do we need to let
people leave their houses
i've lived in boulder county for many
years and one thing i am sure of is this
our community is strong it is kind
it is compassionate and it is resilient
and we will get through this together
as we comfort each other as we begin the
process
of healing in the coming days and weeks
and tough months ahead
i'd now like to turn it over to the
mayor of boulder
i'm actually glad to hear that and who
is this right now this is the mayor
there yeah is that the guy who no you
wanna naked what
i'm away you make it you wanna see him
almost naked okay whatever what was the
the girl that was killed in boulder the
little uh
pageant girl oh yeah i i don't remember
i know what you're talking about
i don't know why where i i lived in
boulder briefly but whenever i they were
like yeah she lived
ramsay i think that might be pineapple
yeah pineapple on your stomach what was
that
i should have brought you come on i have
no idea what you're talking about so
let's go to another argument here with
which is what you will hear um because
they try to point to the air 15. the
second amendment was only intended for
muskets and well-regulated englishes by
the way we've talked about this at great
length
uh the security of a free people there's
a comma
yeah militia being necessary state was a
secure state of free people
militia being necessary yeah for free
people comma
the right to bear and keep armed shall
not be there's a comma and then george
mason was asked
who me who is a militia why it is the
entire people of course
this is something that was clarified not
only when you read it quite literally in
the constitution
but the corroborating founding documents
this needs to be
understood so they have tried to say
that it was only for militias it was
only for muskets this is another one too
yeah what's the militia it's the whole
people you can find quota for quota for
quote from the founding fathers
it was only for muskets right we hear
that a lot well okay look
that would make sense if the only weapon
around at that time
were a musket yeah or particularly if
the other firearms that existed that
were maybe higher capacity more rapid
firing
the founding fathers didn't know about
they had zero forethought right
not only do they know about it they
actually expressly permitted
and encouraged people to use them so
what did we have we had uh
the pepper box revolver with the jiren
dhoni air rifle right
um and then there's a letter from james
madison in 19 in 1787 he wrote a letter
of mark in reprisal to a private ship
saying hey look
i know we have the second amendment but
we have these pirates i don't want to
get in trouble are we allowed to have
cannons and jefferson
why do you feel you need to ask i am not
your king
of course you can have cannons have
someone send me a sketch
this is what i would like to see that a
cannon is at least a bazooka
yeah so when you have when you have the
founding fathers
saying well yeah of course the second
amendment it's so that you can defend
yourself you have pirates they have
cannons you have cannons
you were actually meant to have uh
firearms you're actually meant to have
armaments as effective as what the
military had at that time
yeah well they weren't anti ideas and
they weren't anti-new technology
so why is it even a conversation it's
just a stupid point
right i mean i hate to say it it's just
as bluntly as blunt as i can put it it's
like them saying the first amendment
only applies to the printing press yeah
when you look at these shooters that are
all isolated it's always been a common
thread regardless of they were forced to
this year or not
isolation loneliness sadness depression
tends to trigger people
yeah well yeah and we when we talk about
this we're not talking about
you know fully automatic you know
military weapons that they're talking
about like all the ar-15 i don't know
why the ar-15 is so scary to people it's
probably because they've never fired
oh yeah the gun before unless you're a
new york times reporter in which case
you fire it and you soil yourself and
say that
yeah you had ptsd right but the whole
the whole goal that's an actual
story no yeah remember yeah i forgot it
was like the compression that took place
really my mother-in-law who looks like
sally fields mind you in the
osteoporosis commercials right current
sally field i love her adorable she's a
very slight lady yeah she hit a
bull's-eye at 100 yards with an ar-15
on the first try you know why because an
ar-15 is not that heavy
there's not that much recoil and it's
very easy for women to understand and
operate what are you saying that women
don't know firearms
uh most of them yes so what i'm saying
is you need something simple
that's why i have a nine nine millimeter
handguns and a nine millimeter carbine
rifle why because my wife's like what
goes
where and she's just dropping bullets
into the gun
i don't know so she can grab a bucket of
ammo and put them in any firearm in the
house
in our lake cottage because we have
bears it's 357 it's a carbine rifle and
revolver so that it goes into every
firearm because i don't
i don't when i talk about this here and
i want to encourage everybody out there
to purchase a firearm purchase a firearm
legally right yeah
get of course get proficient in using
that firearm so that you will know and
be able to educate
other people on these myths you need to
know how to use a firearm you need to
exercise your right or you are going to
lose it and i would rather have 50
people out there
i'd rather have 5 000 people with one
firearm
than one person with 50. we need to get
this beyond the realm of hobbyists who
collect guns
and everybody seeing a firearm as a tool
in their household just like a hammer or
a reciprocating saw yeah well and and by
the way this ship has sailed so long ago
right with the no pun intended right so
with the second amendment right you've
got people
i'm pretty sure that was intended and
i'm pretty sure it wasn't a pun
well you've got people out there that
are following the law okay so if you
took
guns away from all law-abiding citizens
today how long would it be
until you got all of them away from
criminals and could you ever fully
guarantee that criminals would never
have weapons no the answer is absolutely
not and if you could that would be a
country that i wouldn't want to live in
that would be a country that takes away
every freedom you have just to make sure
you can't have a firearm
and can't protect yourself right and
there are far more defensive uses of
firearms each time in this year yeah
it's up
it's close to the numbers are hard to
know because a lot of the time people
don't use the firearms they simply
branch the weapon and it
stops the situation from escalating uh
when it's a home invasion of course you
shouldn't be running around like uh
i defend my gun that scott loves raping
that cat he's a character
so uh i i but i do encourage you to to
go uh purchase firearms and two and you
you have a firearm but you said you have
to do too
i do that's a bad idea well let's not
tell the world what i have uh well i
have
uh yeah i have stuff well the reason we
were talking about this because
look and i say this because i have i'm
not a collector every firearm i have has
a purpose right
um and we all have several firearms but
uh you're and i but you're actually
newer
to this but that's a good thing because
i want you to learn how to be safer than
why
a fire what kind of firearm is important
i never shot a gun until i was in my 30s
right i never shot a gun until i was in
my 20s because i was canadian and
the only person who ever knew who had a
handgun was my ex-girlfriend's dad who
had the magical closet of mystery where
it was
illegal it was like an old replica don't
go in there i'm pretty sure that bullet
would have hit you sideways
yeah i have a lot of friends who have
that you know if you want just militias
to have guns good luck
right yeah but at 22. this is something
a lot of people understand this is this
is how tainted your view is from films
like
shoot to kill we saw batman um the
original batman but i hold the gun
sideways
right yeah that's the kill shot to make
sure that it can't recoil properly to
chamber the next
round and you it's like oh no i'm
getting raped
but i looked cool before it so um this
is
what's important for a lot of people
don't realize you think i'll go out and
get a 22.
there is no shoot to kill their shoot to
stop okay shoot to stop if someone is
attacking you
right if you have a home invasion you
are looking for a firearm that you can
fire most effectively that will
stop the assailant before they continue
to do damage
it doesn't matter if you sure more
people are killed by 22 than any other
caliber
but that's because people may die an
hour
and a half later maybe the next day
right in the icu from internal bleeding
but the fact is you're kind of just
poking holes with a 22
and your only chance is if you basically
do kill the guy because there isn't
enough
central nervous system shock so buy a
larger caliber again the idea is to stop
where you get a hollow point pull it
this is something they talk about in
film i was watching uh
was it designated survivor because
thanks for the recommendation
dad and uh
right away there's a scene where some
guy gets sniped and they go i don't
understand
i already make that shot from 600 yards
away you know that comes in detective
we recovered the firearm what it was an
ar-15 sir my god
that's not possible how do they get they
just assume that you're an idiot
the goal is to have a a caliber that
hits someone and causes enough central
nervous system shock regardless of
whether it hits the heart right maybe
it's the spleen
that they stop your goal is not to kill
your goal is to stop and that's why
people talk about
getting a caliber that you can fire
effectively so let's get into hr
127 because all these things that people
don't know they want you to believe that
there's no background check for firearms
there are background checks for firearms
they want you to believe that certain
calibers are only designed to kill
more effectively there are more people
killed with 22s than any other caliber
it doesn't mean that it's more effective
to stop
stop at home invasion these things are
not true but just to be clear
you think i should file the serial
number off of my gun and sell it to a
teenager and then get something bigger
yes and i think that you should only
handle it with saran wrap around perfect
yes i just want to make sure i heard it
yeah right to be safe you should burn
your
fingernail oh i already have just you
living i have sliced them off with a
razor so i can do my
head of the game oh no you live in
detroit you're not necessarily gonna
have to make a trip to plymouth
no you can just i could throw the gun
out and a guy would catch it
thanks bro i'd be like i got five of
these though and when you
when you need a new one you can just
yell olly olly oxen oh wow that was okay
right here
leave a gun take it's called free
enterprise you got competition there's
actually a fishbowl like business cards
yeah it's just full of guns yeah i'm
done with this one
so this is hr 127 which is the bill of
course that will be
uh this would be a national bill what
would it do well they want a national
database of everyone who's licensed to
own a gun and buy ammunition if you're
unlicensed
firearm owners face fines ranging from
75 000 to 150 thousand dollars in
lengthy jail sentences which uh by the
way they've just turned an entire class
of people
law-abiding american citizens who don't
into criminals
yeah think about that yeah we're
supposed to have a right to privacy
because we don't want facebook tracking
uh you know what
what kind of soap we're looking up at
etsy afterward when we're off-site but
you don't have a problem with having to
register
with the federal government if you have
a firearm which by the way can be posted
publicly that's happened they want there
to be a map where people can know
uh it's not in this building a map where
people can know exactly where all the
firearm owners in their neighborhood
it's like a neighborhood watch
only you take out all the neighborhood
watch i love etsy i bought salt and
pepper pepper shakers
really for reals did you push it good
yeah yeah i seriously did buy it
and people are like is that salt and
pepper i'm like yeah yeah they said
that's appropriation
salt and pepper and you should be
ashamed of yourself it should not be
they want a mandatory psychological
evaluation
of the gunfire all family members
including ex-spouses
well that you know you're gonna get a
rave review from your ex-wife who's
fighting over custody
an annual 800 gun insurance fee is
required and this is something else that
people
it just shows how disingenuous the left
is with this right
what does this do this disenfranchises
the poor
they want to say that poor people can't
get voter id which is effectively free
right they just want to do that to
disenfranchise poor people they want to
make sure that black people
and latinos don't vote voter id which is
kind of racist by the way because it's
not assuming they're ports assuming
they're stupid
i don't believe that to be the case but
what do you think happens if you have to
register you face this fine
or you have to pay a minimum of 800
of firearm insurance per year which is
more expensive than the firearm in most
cases
look poor people in detroit poor people
and take your city right trail
white people in trailer parks people
people in koreatown people right now who
are being victimized right
asian americans from hate crimes they
can't afford the luxury of a full-on
security detail aoc
nancy pelosi the best shot they have is
being
able to exercise their second amendment
rights that's why it's a great equalizer
it's the right to self-preservation this
bill gun control
just makes poor people the people in
neighborhoods who are more likely to be
the victim
of gun violence to begin with less safe
let's be really clear about that you
don't care about disenfranchising poor
people how much does it cost to get some
kind of government i know a driver's
license is like 15 bucks something like
that yeah i don't know what it costs you
can get some other form of government id
that i think doesn't cost you anything i
don't know i know it's less than a
recurring
800 fee if you want to make sure that uh
you don't come home and your wife's no
longer there and it ends up like ransom
as a law-abiding citizen is there any
other product that i have to be
treated like this with like any other
product that i'm guaranteed the right to
be able to purchase
uh in in our you know rights the closest
thing i can think of
is if you're 12 years old guaranteed
free condoms from the punch bowl at the
student activities coordinator
flavored oh for her pleasure but really
it's still your pleasure
hope you make responsible decisions 12
year olds uh we can't give you an advil
but here's a
french tickler here's a dental dam yes i
hope you like cherry
it doesn't really taste like cherry it's
more that medicinal flavor but you know
what
it's you'll be glad you had it as long
as it's not the cherry popping daddy so
am i right what a terrible that's a scot
that's a scar band yeah they're terrible
um i mean they're great no offense i
don't want anybody i don't
know i feel like the mountain a hate
mail i'm about to get yeah
for installments what are your thoughts
on real big fish yeah uh
i think we know my thoughts on real big
fish as far as ska bands go at the time
they weren't the worst
but you know it could have been you
heard it dave lando hates real big fish
look i left bloodhound gang a little bit
it was the early 90s
i even tolerated sugar ray for a summer
really
well i didn't like it i'm not a fan of
tolerated i
tolerate it does one heck of a job on
access hollywood though he really
transitioned here's something else
that's in the bill right here i don't
know if we have this language
there's an additional license to own and
possess this is the bill a military
style
weapon ah what does that mean what
that's all it says what did it
what what what does that mean does that
mean one of the most popular handguns
being sold in america today the sig p320
because it just won
i believe it was the army trials or i
don't know if it was the marine trails
they all have some variant to that
that's some that's a military style
weapon what about a i bar
a knife yeah that's not i thought they
were talking about air 15 since it's
similar to the m16 it's not the same gun
interesting interesting that you bring
that up you know what else is not a
military style weapon
an ar-15 it is not used anywhere in the
military
that is an m16 people oh isn't it no
just because it looks the same doesn't
mean it's the same at all
an m16 is a rifle with burst fire one
three shots are fully automatic
it whereas an ar-15 is a civilian
version with semi-automatic fire and
that sounds really scary to people
semi-automatic if you have any gun that
isn't a bolt action or pump shotgun one
trigger pull
one round the difference between your
ar-15
and the military-style m16 is as
significant think of this
if you had to [ __ ] your handgun every
single time [ __ ] it every single time
okay now you go to semi-automatic that's
an ar-15 the difference is about the
same between the ar-15 the military
military-style variant where it has full
automatic or burst fire it is
not used in the military and this is a
problem right
when you ha here's the when you have
bills uh great new deal not with
standing there
like you know four pages and a pop-up
but if you have to get rid of military
it's military-grade weapons they say
military-style weapons with no
definition military style weapons then
what am i supposed to do with my hands
oh
well you know what i would just say
don't register them and just incur the
150 000. but they're already registered
steven as a lethal we're going to get
you if you transition
to david levine uncle sam's none the
wiser
all right i'm gonna keep these bad boys
but then you have to register your uh
vagina so uh this no this register
when we're talking about we're talking
about bills uh again
aoc's green new deal five things also
lethal there are thousands of pages
there are thousands of pages right
there's thousands
how do you have it as vegas weapons that
look like they could be used in an
action movie how does that happen
because they want to be able to define
it whatever looks scary whatever they
happen to think they want off the
streets to make themselves look good
like they're doing something to solve
this problem it all goes back to them
trying to do something for votes and not
actually trying to solve the problem
that we have
right hey didn't i have a didn't we have
a photo shopping i remember someone
deleted it from the show map but i have
no idea
what was there
we know the name of the person uh 21
year old
um ahmed alissa oh
no so doesn't it is he a transgender
terrorist
maybe i was a mad a mad
but i'm in transition haven't that
bottom that i've done top i have a nice
set
also estrogen doesn't really agree with
me so i feel angry
i'm guerrilla made
you must be looking for my brother i'm
alisa middle name stacy
he said and i my uh he
he looked arabic i said that and i
didn't have my nana was at arabic
so don't get old well no we're not
saying arabs like
all arabs are bad we're saying it was is
this they just said he was a white guy
no the media says for us what we say i
didn't mean to catch you
gerald i cut him off yes you did i just
cut him off he needs to be taken down
i know i was just saying that i dip that
other people speak
for us and i'm not saying it's over but
by the way that'll be looked arabic
that'll be included among white shooters
yeah even if he even if he is fresh i
can say fresh off the boat because it
was a sitcom
even if he is fresh off the boat from
iran
from saudi arabia or from north africa
uh
egypt he will still be labeled white
according these statistics
just to be clear that's how you need to
educate yourself so you can know when
they're lying to you and again
we don't know we we found an instagram
uh that might be this guy
it's the same spelling of his name ahmed
uh alisa
and this guy this guy's from colorado
and he's young so oh
um this is one that guy had a bald spot
so was it the allman brothers that sang
sweet alyssa
yeah yeah hold on let me i can't see
this so you guys that's right
oh people listen to me in earnest
worship allah say your five daily
prayers
salah fest during the month of ramadan
and give your wealth
in zakat perform hajj if you can afford
to
the last sermon of the prophet muhammad
so we don't know if this is the guy it
might not be him
he's from colorado the guy is 21. i
don't know that what they showed on the
news of the balding guy if that's a 21
year old
um but who knows what we know right now
about the suspect is this is his name
i love how no known motive right now is
what they're saying on cnn
whereas with massage parlors was right
away anti-asian hate crime
joe biden kamala harris said hey i'm
getting on i'm getting on a plane to go
meet with the asian community of atlanta
how do you do that right and it's not
even just as bad as jumping the gun when
we
know for a fact that there is no
evidence that it was a hate crime it
wasn't targeting
asian people they still run the stories
that it is every single day
should always just wait for them it
doesn't matter this is what this is what
happens when you have a media with no
accountability and then when you have
big tech
trying to look big media lost legacy
media lost they lost to us they lost a
blaze they lost a deadly wire we beat
them on election when
when the playing field is fair their
content cannot compete
and so legacy media in order to avoid
any kind of accountability
has tried to get their claws into big
tech so that it force feeds you cnn and
yes fox news is not exempt either
so that they never get called on their
mistakes look
this is happening in real time they said
that day you when you were hosting the
show that was happening in real time
your joke about the gremlin shot keeper
beard had me in tears in my hotel and my
heart was hurting at mayo clinic so
you're going to have to pay for some new
stitches but that happened in real time
and they said hate crime against asians
and i even admit when i was what i was
like well you know what it looks that
way at this point i did
because i didn't read it takes a while
to read oh wait 30 we're not even asian
oh wait this guy didn't have any history
oh wait these were at massage parlors
where there was sex trafficking which by
the way has been just swept
under the rug and now in real time it's
we have no
idea as to the motive of the shooter
you can start with a med and take a
guess
if you're going to take a guess just
because people who happen to be asian 70
of them at massage parlors and you say
this is a hate crime
take a guess here right if you're going
to do it the point is you shouldn't
guess but you already did
yeah doesn't fit the narrative this guy
we just showed too we're fairly sure
that this is the guy this i'm sorry this
is actually facebook not instagram
but we're fairly sure it is the guy [ __ ]
together
this other tweet uh from aaron uh
katurski the suspect in boulder colorado
ahmed alyssa 21 of arvada and this guy
it says he's from arvada
all right well let's have them comb
through more stuff i'm sure we'll find
uh i'm sure we'll find uplifting little
memes nothing to see here though
is also an instagram ass model look i
also buy my feet
oh geez when i bow to face mecca five
times a day
i'm glad that i do it in gymshark
i have neighbors that do that my dogs
bark
this you can hear the whole call to
prayer and him dynamic yeah yeah oh well
ham travis got a lot of polish though
boy the pierogies you can get there
and duck blood soup you know who's had
that anthony bourdain
and me is it any good it's actually
really good i like that sounds
good i know it sounds terrible i never
ate it until anthony bourdain did
and other than you know how it ended i i
liked him
where i wanted to be like him but don't
don't be like him well we'll see
let's not follow the same path well if
you do
throw yourself over a rail in the ozarks
we've talked about this
yes we have a pact oh yes we do
it's called just the day that media
matters is banging down the door it's
like you know what to do
and we do our swan knife yep that's
right and which is not going to be very
pleasant because our office here is only
two stories but yeah um
really yeah you know we're going to hit
ourselves we're both going to be dressed
as feathers yeah this is like a bad
thumb of louise
it's just me and dave landau and as we
jump with those hands
sisters
suicidal sisters all right no i'll be
dressed like a penguin and they'll be
like see they can't fly
[Laughter]
stephen will go as a ground owl yes yeah
it'll be so funny
[Laughter]
i want to jump from a building and
instead of that like that makeshift sort
of trampoline
i want them to just have a giant box of
ground owls oh though
oh wow you take them both out just you
know put some nice grass and dirt in
there so they can burrow and you know
they're not
they're not the wise to what's going on
they're safe i want to be saved by eight
pigeons and they just grab my coat and
pull me back
and then one says happy birthday um you
deserve it they're like
you won't you won't die from that fall
we're pulling you higher to drop you
although it's like tom and jerry that i
brought my son to see the pigeons will
be rappers
ah well listen detroit it could happen
stranger things have happened like
detroit still being a city
so let's let's move on well we're
talking about
people being allowed to do stuff i don't
know how detroit is allowed to still be
a thing yeah i don't think technically
it's suspenseful we have a dr choi too
oh we have dr choi okay let's see if he
can hold for a few minutes do you think
he can or is he
is he uh uh yeah we'll ask him okay
because we're gonna have to doctor
we basically just just talked about gun
control we have a whole okay let's let's
rattle through this segment really
quickly
all right let's talk about this one and
then we'll get to dr troy we have a
what's up doc with fat pride
so um biden's military this is something
we need to talk about right now
uh the military and i will say this look
thank you to everyone who has served i
appreciate it
uh but the military is not what we once
thought the military has now become a
petri dish a social experiment it's not
about having the most effective military
in the world it's not about having the
most prepared people in the world and of
course when you do that when you turn it
into a social justice experiment
you end up sending unqualified people
largely women
pregnant women now to their deaths
that's so don't say that this doesn't
come from a place of empathy
just like you can't say when we're
talking about people having the right to
bear arms no it does come from a place
of empathy because i don't want women to
get raped i want to read more headlines
that read woman fights off rapist and
attacker with firearm then
raped and left in a ditch same thing
here i don't want to read
more headlines to say pregnant woman who
couldn't do a knee tuck or push-ups ends
up dead in the battlefield okay they
shouldn't be in the battlefield you can
call me sexist i don't give a rat says
cancel moment hi take this clip
so last friday at the international
summit uh in alaska
chinese diplomats uh mocked biden's weak
stance against china
uh mercilessly and um of course i would
never side with communist china
but it got some shots in i have to tell
you
what i'm hearing is very different from
what you described
i'm hearing deep satisfaction that the
united states is back
that we're re-engaged with our allies in
part the chinese diplomats right now i'm
also here purple head
[ __ ] about some of the actions your
government
is taking well no bodies seriously when
you're sitting next to a cabbage pad
we thought that the u.s side will follow
the necessary diplomatic protocols
so for china it was necessary that we
make our position
clear
so let me say here that in front of the
chinese side the united states does not
have the qualification to say that it
wants to speak to china
from a position of strength yeah from a
position of strength strength that was
the word where we couldn't find the clip
because it got cut off because it was
pretty embarrassing
just like the guy's balls oh
you're saying we're not strong i'm
saying pound-foot-pound
you are a possibility so
we need not worry though because former
vice president joe biden he knows
uh he knows that national security is
not achieved through strength no that's
not what the military is about
you guys are all concerned about power
and strength and efficiency
it's achieved through diversity they're
using their voices
and actively working to change policies
in the military to make it easier and
safer
for more women not just to join the
military
but to stay in the military and to
thrive
i'm incredibly proud that in 2015 under
the obama biden administration we took
the final steps
to open up all positions in the military
to anyone qualified to serve in them
joining today's military aren't told
no they should be told no i don't know
when the military
i don't know the military became an
all-inclusive this isn't sandals
they should be told no if they said more
people
who qual people who qualify what if they
don't qualify we'll reduce the
qualifications what if they still don't
qualify
then we'll just reduce all
qualifications and the chinese will
laugh at us okay well
that's really what we're going to do so
let's look at a couple of things here
before we get to women sorry women
are you saying that women are weaker
than men physically yes you're weaker
than men period okay you shouldn't be in
the military if you're pregnant i don't
understand why we're talking about this
but one of the executive orders that was
issued by joe biden
former vice president joe biden free
transgender surgery in the military
reversing an obama-era policy uh
that's nice that's nice that's that's a
priority right now
imagine that in pearl harbor when people
are that's the thing people were holed
up there in their hospital beds how many
people would have been able to run out
to their
fighter jet well back then they weren't
jets been able to run out to their
what do they use not it was between
biplanes and fighter jets but they
couldn't unless they
hurt the sutures in their groin all
right hold on i gotta waddle out there
that's all that did oh hold on i'm
bleeding from my crotch
i gotta use my medical device like a
barbershop quartet
to reopen it as a wound oh stop it well
the beginning of saving private ryan
actually
is because of uh vagina suitors
sutures sorry from the joke so this is
which explains by the way hollywood yet
another remake uh taking their chances
with uh
redo of missing in action and that seems
yeah well you know what i don't know how
else you expect that's missing
that's to go uh and this is one thing me
saying this
and by the way the best thing you can do
right now while you're watching the show
is just comment
comment comment just leave a comment
what you think about women in the
military
and what you think not only about women
in the military because everyone agreed
women in the military officers women in
the military anything that involves
intellectual capacity because women are
justice organizational capacities
sure and you know what even pilots
provided they aren't with child but i'm
about to say a phrase
that you on its face would
think is a sketch would think it's a bit
it's not
biden oh let me just read this verb
verbatim from this article
biden also announced the priority of
special maternity fighter pilot suits
for pregnant women where we're making
good progress designing body armor that
fits women properly tailoring combat
uniforms
for women creating maternity flight
suits and
updating updating requirements for their
hairstyles toss some spandex on their
fatigues and call it a day
this is remarkable to me hey look when
we're a society where the military is no
longer about protecting women and
children
yeah and do we really need how many g's
can that baby take
do we really need another no bid
military terry contract for maternity
suits like just have a bidding war
between
talbots and whoever i don't know
whatever else is talbot's but the point
is
you know what you know what women
shouldn't be able to do when they're
pregnant
fly fly okay it's not peter pan you
think of happy thoughts you can still
die just to be clear
it's safest for pregnant women to fly
only between three and six months i know
because of a wife pregnant with twins
and they said don't fly not the first
trimester not the last trimester and
unless you're with twins guess what you
probably don't need another suit
you just need to leave a little bit of
room for the belly also
that baby is going to be mashed potatoes
at that point
it is disgusting we shouldn't be sending
oh
women handle g-force better really what
about the six-month-old
do you have any that's the scariest ride
in the world well that woman's out there
reenacting torah torah torah
i can't believe that we are now saying
the military is not about being
as effective as possible because at one
point our goal was to protect women and
children
why because we love them why because
they make babies why
because men are fine being leathernecked
rough
they'd be doing this out there deer
hunting on that weekend
anyway they don't give a rat's ass
switch the deer out with a terrorist
and switch that hunting rifle with an
m16 not ar-15 unless you're an idiot
right that's what i want those are the
people that i want in the military also
the people in the military who i want
people who are able to do basic push-ups
not knee push-ups
non-bitch push-ups how about that
before we start talking about joe biden
just likes to spend money
oh yeah maternity flight suits are you
out of your mind
you know what happened to goose what do
you think's gonna happen to mother goose
well i think we are denying the super
soldier depending on her mood
yes ah i mean we could really take out
the trash
they don't need to give them
methamphetamine like the japanese coming
out they don't know
like she killed everybody even in her
own platoon
they get that extra mother adrenaline
well i called her through her headset
and i said remember those cadbury eggs
that
i was saving for you i got hungry at
night and ate them
she said her ankles hurt and i suggested
larger boots because they might be
swelling
yeah she murdered nine asian men and
she's headed for the white house so you
guys might
want to get him in those uh canals my
gosh um
you know what else can't do first off
the first thing to tell you
is right don't now even say we can have
a glass of wine yeah you can have a cup
of coffee
but stress avoid stress right do you
think a dog fight in the sky might
qualify
especially because you know what else
women can't do pregnant women they can't
ride roller coasters
they can't get in hot tubs but we're
gonna put them in a fighter jet i'm
sorry it's not sexist to not want
pregnant women to
die in the military here's something
else too 65
of women have been failing the new mind
you new
equal gender neutral fitness test versus
just 10 of men
this is important to note this is a new
gender neutral fitness test what does
that mean
we've made it easier because women
weren't passing the other tests so now
it's
you don't even have you don't have to do
other things that were hard like pull
ups and stuff like that
so we're going to make it really easy
where you know you do like a knee tuck
but guess what
women are underperforming in the knee
tuck
1.9 women for every 8.3 men
pass oh man so the military provided
another option do you know what it is do
you know what it is what here it is
it is it is the shameful
red-headed stepchild of the planking
which is the stupidest thing in the
world again because you should do
push-ups when you're doing a push-up
guess what you're always planking but
we're going to remove that from the
equation
and just sit there so now they allow
women to you know
because they have to get up in their
maternity flight suits so otherwise well
how could you how could
you're a patriarchy so let's make sure
we lower the standards so that women
with
child can get up there in an f-16 if i
don't know what the plane is f-16 f-15 i
don't know apache whatever it is
whatever the hell it is let's make sure
they can get up there so let's remove
the knee tuck
and let's just have them do an internet
movement
just balance on the belly that's not
even as hard as the ice bucket
challenge so now women can go out into
the front of combat
with planking um and that actually
reminds us
i know we have to get going we're
running late today so hopefully dr choi
is still there and if he's not then i
understand but uh
uh we wanted to put this to the test
herself so it's time to bring in some
interns
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so we have a boy in turn and a
lady intern uh
hey how you doing troy junior good not
the victim of any hate crimes lately
all right you just let me know if that
happens around this office because there
are things that i tolerate the one thing
i don't tolerate in this office
racially motivated hate crimes oh yeah
well not the ones i see
he'll give you what you need for an
extra 50.
whoa all right so we are just going so
for the rest of the show guys get down
get into the plank
and uh we're gonna see who wins the uh
boy
oh those are maternity pants we have
maternity flight suit pants
all right both of you plank i have to
finish the show oh joe lucy
stay there for the whole show i can't
see them so you guys let me know if one
of them fails
okay hey hey no no no you can't get no
don't get rid of joe lewis well that
could be a terrorist out there with your
platoon yeah part of the deal was out
there
get on the ground crying out loud
we want you protecting our country and
you can't deal with a few licks
hey hey hey don't be a [ __ ] thank you
thank you sir man
i'm just telling you he loves you all
right this is part of this this is part
when he mounts you freeze yes just it's
best to let him finish
here's another thing is now the woke be
it the navy i really like
but we're seeing they're forcing all
sailors to re-swear their oaths to the
constitution
uh in order to try and weed out
extremism here you go
extremist beliefs behaviors and conduct
are not consistent with our core values
they have no place within our navy or
our navy culture
extremist organizations are those that
promote
supremacist causes and discriminate
against
others based solely on race creed
color sex religion sexual preference
or national origin or those that
advocate the use of violence
against our government and elected
leaders beyond our core values
this kind of behavior is in direct
conflict
with the oath that we all swore when we
entered the service
participation and extremism can include
demonstrating
rallying fundraising recruiting or
conducting training for or with
an organization with those beliefs just
by posting retweeting or liking an
offensive all right that's enough i
don't give a rat that's what this guy
has to say
i got a far cry from macarthur with a
deep corn cob
yeah i'm impressed with the planking i
mean i
so here's something else that this uh
this uh chief naval personnel
vice admiral john nolan said the stand
downs will focus on the damaging effects
of extremism and how to eliminate it
after dozens of veterans and service
members were arrested in connection with
the january 6 riot us capital we will
not tolerate those who participate in
actions that go against the fundamental
principles of the oath we share
particularly
actions associated with extremists or
diso dissident ideologies
i thought we had a i thought we had a
sketch
and by the way this is something that
they also have said in the navy this has
become a social experiment it's not
about again it's not about
keeping our country safe that's the
issue right now with the military
um master sergeant ramon colon lopez
hopefully i get that right probably
didn't get it right okay
attributed to racism let's have him
pronounce crowder
i think just saying master sergeant's
going to piss people off yeah maybe
well you know what that's the
implication that's the rank hopefully he
earned it and it wasn't a slot
so the military needs to educate
soldiers on the difference between
capital rights and black lives matter so
they want to make it really clear that
the 200 people
out of all the folks on the capitol
about 250 to
400 000 depending on the estimates you
use that that is a threat but not the
people who've done two billion dollars
in damages causing hundreds of
officer casualties and dozens of deaths
so it says what i'm committed to do is
make sure that our people understand
right from wrong
that our people are well educated to be
able to carry on in an honorable fashion
in their maternity suits
and if they hear somebody saying the
wrong things that they're quick to go
ahead and
correct them without being
confrontational so they want to make
sure
that you educate your fellow members of
the military fellow service members
if they happen to have a problem with
their neighborhoods back home they're
getting a letter and it's not just a
topless pick from their wife
but it's their wife being burned down in
their house that he doesn't hold a
grudge
oh great fair
so they said you can just for
demonstrating just for marching in a
peaceful approach just for retweeting
for liking any of that in other words
some guy who's in the military who's
tasked with going out there and taking
out you know
making gaddafi's little hut look like
kell's uh
bachelor pad right we need to make sure
that he hasn't liked a tweet that
happens to have something that could be
considered islamophobic like this show
well and yeah unless you think that
we're being sarcastic here the people
that were marching
in uh michigan the second amendment
rally were viewed as extremists
for carrying rifles even though they
didn't have a rally they did nothing
wrong they didn't do any damage they
didn't hurt anybody
extremists so you're gonna kick that guy
out of the military for that hey
question question i know we have to get
going soon with dr troy dr choi thank
you so much i know your doctor i know
you're very busy
but um if people always say that well
black lives matter there were just a few
people who co-opted these
and most of them the vast majority of
them were peaceful which is not true
well why don't we say the same when
there were only 200 or so people who
were involved with the capital right
when there were hundreds of thousands of
people there
i have to call an insurance well it
doesn't fit the narrative it doesn't
really make it it doesn't
win yeah 90 how do you have 90 peaceful
anything
with 2 billion dollars in damage damn it
how does that ever happen it just
becomes unpeaceful once it starts like
that
yeah yeah exactly it doesn't matter i
don't know i say what else are they
supposed to do
all right and by the way china would
agree with some of these things because
uh
they called the united states chinese
media hypocrites for supporting hong
kong
and then denouncing the january sixth
rioters
but you know what that's one i guess
china they i guess they kind of i see
how they could see it that way
sure jerks i hate that the chinese are
put pulling one over on i know right
i hate that the chinese are actually
able to
just embarrass our president with i know
you are but what am i
and it works yeah and it works it works
right now
think about this zheng ping how are you
pronounced is more of a man than
former vice president joe biden in some
ways yeah not a fan of communist china
don't get me wrong
and by the way while the us military is
concerned with diversity and inclusion
again haven't pronounced landau uh has
told the military to
prepare for war so uh they're going all
right
prepare for war and they did a little
march little goose step we're like all
right
make sure you have your your gravel
anti-nausea medication
some snacks you guys have the stretchy
pants okay someone help her into the
fight
if someone help her into the fighter jet
oh my gosh there's 19
chinese on us and we're already dead
that's just remarkable to me
they would never consider this and you
know why well first off it's a horrible
communist country china
but we've always understood the military
exists to protect our country
and to protect our women and children we
don't send children out into war
we don't send pregnant women out to war
it's not because we hate women
also uh i don't know that we should be
paying for transgender surgery because i
think there are a lot of people right
now who are going to join up in the army
national guard you can
chop and then they're going to be out do
one tour and out so they can get a free
snip snip i have a problem with i'm just
i'm saying
read between the lines nuance liberals
so the best thing you can do right now
is comment comment
just let us know what you think about
the military situation what you think
about the [ __ ] any information that you
see about the shooting uh
or the shooter please do leave in the
comments section because we'll be
scanning them to try and keep you
updated as this unfolds
we're going to go to mug club we have dr
choi on a fat pride segment what's up
doc youtube thank you i would say we
love you but you know that would be a
lie and i just want to be upfront with
you so you can